when i got out here out to la i studied
with a great acting coach
um who has coached
five or six people friends of mine i
know all of them
have won or been nominated for an oscar
and uh
i am like the black sheep of his class i
have nothing
i thought if you just go to class you
get a nomination one of the most popular
shows ever in the world yeah no
but no there's not i didn't apparently
it's
not fair to complete that if you take if
you study with him
you get an oscar oh i love that though i
love that you are you're still friends
with all those people that's kind of
cool that y'all all
in the beginning yeah you know what we
had in this in the kaminsky method
michael douglas is an acting coach and
and these kids are aspiring
actors when i was in class i remember we
loved being in class
and then if you ever got a gig it was
it was more like i don't want to go do i
want to just stay in class like no you
have to go out into the world
it was there was something very warm and
safe about the
class and yeah they've re-created that
on the show
it's uh it's we had an episode last year
where i
got up and my character spoke in front
of the acting class and
all these memories came back of what
that felt like it's sort of like
yeah or borderline therapy you know
you're standing in or aa me
you know standing in front of people and
opening your soul and uh
it was it was really quite a flashback
to do it
that's cool yep i'm still here just
waiting for you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever